this time around we have a seamless
world all right
a world without any loading time a wall
where you can explore it's set in a city
a modern cities are sent present-day set
in during one night and you you
basically explore this modern city and
you explore Dracula's castle which is
part of the city so the city is growing
around the castle we have a free camera
which gives you the ability to look
around and see if you missed anything
and we have a world that gets
progressively opened as you as you
progress through the story you will get
to explore new areas and as the city
becomes bigger you will need to teleport
to and from the castle in the city and
you know you find an item that allows
you to do that and at the end the whole
world becomes connected this is a modern
city that we haven't seen before in a
video game so you know we're not going
to drop Dracula in the middle of Times
Square and you know sort of having
fumble around and New York or anything
like that this is a city very much that
fits the cost of any universe you know
gothic design it's very much like a you
know a regular European city like Madrid
or I'm even Cologne you know when you
have kind of old and new together I
think the body is going to be both
police and surprise about I'll take on
how a modern castle then and see if it
would look like and that was key in the
design choices that we made for the city
that felt like a Castlevania game
and we wanted there to be a lot of
variety in the environment so it felt
like it was different in everywhere that
he went
every time you turned a corner there was
something new to see something exciting
to see different lighting different
elements you know huge vistas you know
really cool architecture statues that
kind of stuff we are we are in Spain in
an area or Castile which is basically
castle area and there are a lot of
castles here that we are able to take
inspiration from and then of course you
know Hungary and Eastern Europe and that
kind of architecture is a very much
played into this as well you know
Transylvania wallach here those kind of
areas that are referenced in the game
many of the design choices that we took
taken directly from real buildings and
real architecture we love New York
buildings neoclassical buildings you
know we thought that they were very very
suited for a castlevania city I think
one of the cool things about Castlevania
in general and certainly about little
shadow was having the enemies and the
variety of enemies that you had so I
think there's lots of very unique boss
battles in the game
you're gonna see lots of new enemies and
new characters you haven't seen before
especially you know being set in the
modern era having modern weaponry or
modern enemies to took up against is an
interesting proposition especially when
you have these kind of old our swords
and you know chaos floors and whips and
stuff you know fighting modern weaponry
is something I think there's going to be
really exciting Satan coming back to
earth you know is a real danger and is
something that's a threat that's there
throughout the whole game and you know I
have to say that Satan this time around
he knows that he's facing a very
powerful foe so he's ready when he comes
back he's ready and they know it's a
very different Satan to the one that we
saw at the end of the little show one
not just in design terms but in terms of
character in terms of how he's evolved
as character and his motivations and the
things that he wants to achieve him
coming back to take over the world so
it's what's really cool is the
confrontation between Dracula and Satan
is very very powerful and I think it's
going to really satisfy players to see
the changes that we've made to Satan as
a character
your destiny
mommy